hello and welcome everyone it's active
guest stream
33.1 January 17 2023
we are here with Ali and alireza modir
shanichi we're going to hear about the
taxonomy of surprise definitions there
will first be a presentation followed by
a discussion
so Ali Reza thank you for joining please
take it away with the presentation we'll
be looking forward to this and the
discussion
thank you very much Daniel and Ali for
inviting me
um so as you said I'm going to talk
about a taxonomy of surprise definitions
uh which is um basically all the
materials or most of the materials that
we publish in this recent paper in the
Journal of mathematical psychology uh
that is a joint work with johanni Brea
and Wolfram gerstner and lufranker is my
PhD supervisor
so talking about surprise let's start
with a simple top experiment
um let's say that you want to plan
something for your weekend and to plan
something for the weekend we need
information like how the weather is
going to be or we can plan something
and or some cues like the spring that
are informative about the weather of the
weekend or that uh the weather forecast
says is going to be sunny
given these queues we can make some
predictions that oh weather forecast
said it's sunny and it's spring so most
likely it's going to be sunny
let's say that is Friday evening you
plan that for example go for a bike you
go to sleep wake up the day after uh
open the window and it's snowing and
seeing this note given that you expected
the sunny weather this mismatch is
what's been uh natural language would
agree on that it's a feeling of surprise
you know we can easily talk about this
moment say that yeah I was surprised
because I had planned to go for a bike
but then in scientific Community we can
ask this question that for these moments
that you see a snowy weather when
opening the window what does really
happen in our brain
and uh
lots of literature in a long lasting
debate in neuroscience and psychology
about different roles of surprise in the
brain and there's this slew of different
uh what I call surprise related signal
things like prediction error free energy
surprisal or Bayesian surprise and
people say that these things are related
to learning play important role in model
building or predictive coding some
people say that they're quite important
for exploration for example surprising
even attract attention or drive
curiosity
uh there are also literature and memory
that surprising events um
segments or continuous stream of
observation so they help us to segment
our memory and of course there are lots
of work and physiological signals of uh
surprise signals for example when there
is something surprising your pupil
dilates or EG signal has a peak and so
on so forth
the thing is that if I enable look at
this picture and from far away it seems
like that surprises everywhere in the
brain
but then the puzzle is that it's really
the surprise in the sentence surprise
martial synaptic elasticity same as the
one in the sentence surprise Drive
curiosity or not
that's basically the motivation of the
main motivation of our work that uh
different studies in neuroscience and
psychology use similar words but to
refer to different aspects of the moment
of surprise
and I would call this art piece the
moment of surprise and uh basically the
thing is that different studies
different experiment different paper
they all talk about moments like these
situations like this that we can all
agree on to call it a surprising moment
but they talk about different aspects of
it
the way that some we summarize it or put
it in verb in words in the abstract of
the paper was there is no consensus on
the definition of surprise when I posted
the paper online on Twitter
the linguist margin has to laugh
wrote in reply that it's unsurprising
that there is no consensus on the
definition of surprise because it's not
a technical term everyday words are
usually somewhat awake and uniform
definitions are desirable only for
technical terms of science and I cannot
agree more with that and I want to
emphasize that today I'm not going to
talk about the meaning of surprise when
we talk over a coffee break
it's in the context of neuroscience and
psychology and when we talk about these
moments and the role of these surprise
related signals in the brain
so people are going to details and math
and all the framework
um I want to present the paper in a
nutshell that what is the Absurd of the
paper
what we do is that we take many papers
from the field and we identify several
definition of surprise at least 10 of
the definitions here in the paper that
are 18 with all the details and these
definitions include things like ansar
reward prediction error confidence
corrected surprise Bayesian surprise
positive surprise and many things that
people really use in different contexts
then we ask this question that what are
their similarity and differences between
these different surprise definition and
we have three main results that is uh
analyzing these different definitions
from different aspects well first main
result is a technical classification
so to talk about the technical
classification I would like to introduce
a short notation
we call observation y we call Q's X
things that are going to be informative
about the observation
and then predictions can be seen as
either a probability distribution over
the observation given the cues or one
estimate of the next observation
and looking at this uh surprise
definition we could
um identify a category of these
definitions that what we call
observation mismatch to price definition
they only depend on the next estimate so
they don't care that okay what does the
probability of weather being sunny or
rainy or snowy they say that I predict
that the weather is going to be sunny
and now it's not sunny and what is the
difference between being sunny and being
snowy and that's the surprise there is
another group that we call probabilistic
mismatch they actually look at this
distribution and say that oh
uh it's true that I didn't expect the
snowy weather but it was not too
unlikely so it may be not as surprising
as I would expect it so they work with
the with a distribution instead of a
single point estimate or predictor
um
actually this uh conditional
distribution is a marginalization of
something bigger
because there is actually some
uncertainty about what how accurate for
example weather forecast is about the
weather of the next day and that what we
would call I would put in this parameter
Theta that are underlying rules of the
environment or hypothesis the
reliability of the weather forecast and
we don't have access to the true value
of it so we make it believe and this Pi
of theta is our belief it's a
distribution over these possibilities
and actually the marginal distribution
of next observation given the queue is
this marginal probability and the third
group of the surprise definitions people
defining these definitions uh argue that
actually what we care about is this
belief that for example how much we
learn how much we change this belief uh
by observing a new
new observation and those are the
definitions that we call belief
mismatched surprise definitions
so this was a technical classification
we put different definitions in three
different groups and say that there is
some uh difference in how they depend on
uh the belief of subject
then we go to a conceptual labeling and
that's what we call the taxonomy
and we talk about what is the concept or
what is the conceptual arguments behind
the definition of each of each of these
surprise definition
one group uh that's what we call
prediction surprise so they uh they care
about how accurate or inaccurate the
prediction is how expected or unexpected
the next observation is
the more accurate the less surprising
the observation then there's another
category that we call change Point
detection surprise
they don't only care about the
prediction they always compare
prediction with a baseline prediction
if something is unexpected but that
thing is unexpected under any hypothesis
then they claim that is not surprising
because it would be just kind of uh an
outlier so I should not consider it as
surprising and these are important to
detect change points
um because
what they care about is to see if there
is another hypothesis under reach the
current observation would be more likely
for example in this case of weather
forecast during covet time there was
this argument that there is this paper
I'm citing here that because there is
much less flight uh going on we had way
less data and sensors so weather
forecast suddenly stopped being accurate
and actually if you were checking
weather forecasts you could see uh
without even knowing the news that uh it
gets less and less accurate as time pass
on and this kind of change Point
detection surprise definitions are
somehow optimal I show later on that
they're optimal for detecting these kind
of unobserved changes
uh the third group or the third class
are what we call Information Gain
surprise so no matter if there is a
change or not uh this new observation
made me learn something more about those
underlying rules of the environment so
uh which
Media or which weather forecast is more
reliable than the others every day that
I see the weather I would use that to
update my belief about different weather
forecasts
and the last category is no matter which
of these ones I care about what what is
the concept behind the what is the
conceptual argument behind the
definition the argument is that if I'm
more confident if I'm more confident
about my prediction I should feel more
surprised so the argument is that no
matter what is the definition I should
have an explicit term for confidence in
my definition
so having this technical classification
and this conceptual labeling we can
arrange this list of surprise definition
in this different boxes and have some
structure and as you can see some of
these boxes are empty and I would like
to say
you know we have these mathematical
definitions on the side but their
justification come from the relation to
experience uh to uh experiments and uh
what they tell us about the brain so it
can be the case that in future we see
that none of these definitions are
helpful or we see in some situation that
we need another definitions and this uh
figure here tell us that okay there are
actually a
places that we can come up with new
definitions in new categories
but there are also restriction for
example talking about Information Gain
if we want to talk about Information
Gain we should always talk about the
belief mismatch we cannot talk about
only at the level of observation or
marginal distribution because we are
talking about learning so we should talk
about these very high level uh hidden
variables or when we talk about
confidence we inevitably we need to talk
about probability distribution and we
cannot talk about Point estimates but uh
still we can talk about these three
different uh empty boxes here
and or last main result is although
these different definitions are in
different boxes but there are some links
between them so we found conditions
under which these definitions are
indistinguishable so there are some
situation that they're wanted on mapping
uh there is one-to-one mapping between
some of these definitions we cannot
really experimentally distinguish them
so um that was a summary of our work and
now I'm going to go uh to the
mathematical framework and go one for
one through all of these definitions and
they're linked to each other and please
let me know if there is any um
clarification question
so for mathematical framework
Let's uh look at one very traditional
experiment experiments for studying
surprise in the field of Neuroscience
it's what what's called volatile audible
task
uh in a typical output task at each time
point we have two possibility for uh the
stimulus it's either for example here a
blue disc or a red square
and for a while the blue disc is much
less likely to appear on the screen than
the other one and the
reasoning behind the design of this
experiment is that the participants who
is watching this sequence on the screen
one after another
expect to see a
the red screen more often than the blue
disc and at the moment that it sees uh
he or she sees the blue disc it's uh
it's surprising and that would give them
a feeling of surprise
and a question that one can ask is that
can we really quantify how surprised a
participant feels at time t equal to
four so if we know that this is the
sequence until time t equal to 4 can be
Quantified the amount of surprise or not
and to talk about the feeling of
participant about surprise of a surprise
of an observation we should make some
assumption about how participants
perceive this sequence
and we take it very common Assumption of
the field that participants perceive
their sensory observation as
probabilistic outcomes of a generative
model with hidden variables so at each
time each of these observation come from
some distribution with some hidden
variable for example the way that
participants we assume in a way that the
way that participants think about the
sequence of observation is that at each
time with some probability uh one of
these uh stimuli appear on the screen
and over time given the sequence they
try to find this probability
uh to formally Define this we consider a
generative model
let's say that at time T we show the
observation what appear on the screen by
YT and there is this hidden variable
which we call environment parameters
which is for example the probability of
blue disk appearing on the screen
and now this link for people who are
familiar with and going to make a
Bayesian Network and this link shows
that the environment parameter determine
the distribution over the observation
and I can repeat the same thing for time
t plus one
something that I didn't talk about in
these volatile Oddball task is that for
a while we had this uh one image after
another with some fixed probability but
once in a while we have a hidden change
point which changed the probability of
blue disk and red square so previously
bluedisk was rare and after that the
other one can be rare or frequent
so the environment parameter over time
can change so we defined this parameter
uh this random variable change Point
indicator that at time t plus one if it
is one it means that there is a change
in the environment there is a new
parameter and if it is zero it basically
means that there is no change the
environment is stable and Theta t plus
one is a copy paste of Teta T So this
link just take that a t and take it to
theta plus t plus one
um so far the way that I present this in
uh this task uh was that different
observations are independent of each
other so at each time one of these
stimuli appear on the screen randomly
um this very beautiful paperless manual
and uh colleague in 2016 in Pillars
computational biology they argued it's
very nice they argue that even if the
sequence of observation is randomly uh
designed so this observation are
independent of each other
people when they are observing this
sequence assume that there's some
dependency so they what they uh what
they estimate over time is not really
probability of observing the blue disc
or Red Square they are estimating the
probability of observing blue disk after
Red Square or Red Square after Red
Square so what they assume is that
there's a link between y t and YT plus
one
so so far I have a model of this uh
Oddball task that says that each
observation depends on the environment
parameter and the previous observation
and there is a dynamic for this
environment parameter I do a bit of
trick just Define this dummy variable
which I call Q and for the Oddball task
I just copy paste the previous
observation in the queue but it uh the
reason that we use Q is to have a one
abstract notion of what is um what has
predictive power for the for predicting
next observation and for the for the
task with the action action can go to Q
for the example of the weather forecast
weather forecast can go to the queue and
all these things
and um now having this Motif I can
repeat it and make the whole sequence
and given this generative model given
this mathematical model of the
experiment I can now mathematically
Define the surprise of observing variety
plus one so with this assumption we can
uh we can propose some quantification of
surprise of one stimuli
and uh what is force mentioning is that
this generative model here is
generalization of many other models in
the field which means that many of the
experiments already done to study
surprise can be modeled by this
generative model and a results hold for
that
okay
um before going forward this generative
model also account for these uh moment
of surprise can model that that the Q
was X is here the observation was the
weather of next day is here and Theta
was environment's parameter was how
reliable for example the weather
forecast is about the next observation
and the change point is whether
something happened in the environment
for example the pandemic and decreasing
the number of planes
okay
and now I'm going to make this
definition more formal and discuss the
Dynamics of each of these different
levels of in the generative model
so
I start with the observations
and we assume this is the probability of
at time t plus 1 observing y condition
on Q being X and parameter being Theta
and basically this equation here means
that this probability is time
independent so as long as I know the Q
and the parameter it doesn't matter that
if it's time Step 1 or time step t
in all the time the same distribution
which we uh show by pfy given X
so basically any change in the
environment goes to the parameter and
the distribution is fixed
um for the Q variables we don't put any
constraint and for example
it can even be independent of anything
that's object assumed which is the for
example for weather forecast uh
you just turn on the TV and see what's
going to be the prediction for next
state
then we have the change points indicator
and their Dynamic is at each time
independently we ask whether there is a
change or not and CT plus one and time t
plus one is a bernardly binary sample
with probability of PC which is the
chain what we call change Point
probability
so at each time point with probability
PC there is either a change or not
then um this is the
most important in a way part of the
model that
how this parameters change over time we
consider prior belief Pi zero and say
that at time one before the experiment
starts participants have some uh
assumption and some belief about what
are the parameters Behind these uh
generative process
and uh that we show with pi zero
and at time T if there is no change in
the environment if c t plus 1 is equal
to zero Theta t plus one is just copy
paste of theta T but if there is a
change in the environment we assume that
Theta t plus one is sampled again
independently of past from this prior
belief
so we have a stable environment with the
same data until CT plus 1 is equal to
one then we have a change in the
environment and a parameters is uh
resampled from these prior belief
um
these equations that I wrote here is
fully describe the joint distribution of
C1 to c t plus one Theta 1 to T Theta t
plus one and so on and so forth the
whole generative model is described by
these definitions but if you want to see
the precise mathematical definition
please look at the definition one in the
paper
before going forward I would like to
show some notation that uh whenever I
write something like this
I shortened the vendors whenever there's
no ambiguity I shortened with the
notation by dropping the random
variables that are uh the capital
letters
um then I Define what I call observers
belief at time T if you remember Pi zero
I Define it as initial belief and now Pi
T is the Observer belief at time T that
is given that I observe y1 to YT with
q's X1 to x t what is my
knowledge about the current parameters
of the environment which basically can
be summarized in the posterior
probability of theta T given the
previous cues and observation
um
which in this example is that given a
sequence of days and a prediction of the
weather forecast I can make a belief on
how reliable the weather forecast is at
time t
and at the end they Define this marginal
probability which is the probability of
Y given X and now I dropped Theta and I
put the knowledge here and integrate
over all possibility that if the world
is at time t
how my knowledge about the world
identify the relation between q and
observations
so this was uh the mathematical
framework and given this mathematical
framework now I can go to a formal
investigation of different definitions
and uh present or classification in
distinguishability condition and
taxonomy
what is surprise
having this model I can ask this
question that condition on the previous
observations y1 to T and Q variables X1
to t plus one these ones and these ones
how surprising is the next observation
YT plus one
we are at time t we are going to observe
YT plus one and this is now a valid
mathematical question in this framework
to make some prediction about YT plus
one I need information about Teta T and
x t plus one that is the Q and these are
the rules of the environment whatever I
know about the rules of the environment
is summarized in my belief in my uh
in whatever knowledge this uh
observation and previous cues gave me
about t
and uh given the belief and the queue I
can get rid of I can put away throw away
all the previous observation and say
that I only need the belief and the Q
and surprise is basically a function
that gets us arguments the belief the uh
the queue and the next observation and
give a real value back
one famous example is what people call
surprisal or uh Shannon's surprise the
history is so long it has been used for
so long that I cannot really
going to the first paper that use it but
you can look at the paper of barter in
2013 for a review
which basically
space IQ and an observation
surprise of uh this observation is equal
to minus logarithm of marginal
probability so the more likely this
observation the less surprising it is
there's also another way to define it
which
um because here I had the knowledge at
time t one can say that there was a
possibility to have a change Point here
and uh one can extend this probability
and say that oh there was a
when I'm at time T and I'm predicting
the next observation I should also
consider this possibility that the Vault
may change in between and I should put
some weights on this prior knowledge so
the next observation comes with some
probability from the current Volt or
from the uh prior to terminal word that
is recent
uh so there are two possibilities for
these definitions and
um what I want to emphasize is that in
volatile environments we are not sure
which one we should take necessarily one
may say that the this definition makes
more sense because it's the full
probability but there are experimental
evidence in this paper of Nassau and
colleague in 2010 in the Journal of
Neuroscience
what they argue is that when people
observe YT plus one they update their
knowledge by assuming that there might
have been a change
but when they predict the next
observation they don't consider that
there may be a change
so in a way when people are thinking
about the future they don't consider
this possibility of a change
um and in this sense uh we argue that
the first definition uh the one that I
call S of sh2 is more consistent with
the experimental evidence but through
the paper we take all these two versions
it appears for many of the definitions
and we do really this tedious job of
keeping all these definitions through
the whole paper but today in the talk I
only present one version of each
definition
so this was one of the examples I can
have I can present different examples of
surprise definition in the field uh with
three of them I'm going to present the
first uh
classification that we have the first
one was Channel surprise another one is
the absolute error as I said before one
can say that
given the belief that I currently have I
can make a prediction for example take
the average of these uh marginal
probability and then the difference
between these average these that was my
prediction uh and the difference between
the average and the true observations in
the actual observation is defined as a
surprise
is some sort of prediction error
and there's also this other definition
of very famous definition Bayesian
surprise that says that
I don't care that uh what is the
difference between YT or Y hat and what
is this marginal probability what I care
about is that
by observing up and observing this YT
plus one
how much I update my knowledge about the
world and what is the difference dkl
here stands for kale Divergence between
the belief before observing YT plus one
and after observing YT plus one
um it is not written in the form of YT
Plus One X plus one and Pi T but uh in
proposing in remark 2 in the paper we
show that if PC if probability of change
was equal to zero so if there were no
change in the environment
Bayesian surprise could be written as a
difference between expected Channel
surprise and Shannon surprise itself and
funnily enough the channel surprise here
appeared with the negative sign
so um it seems like that the Bayesian
Superstition Channel surprise are really
complementary uh definitions
and uh particularly it is important to
say that we cannot really get rid of uh
the belief belief really appears remains
here so we have marginal probabilities
here but we also need the belief to
evaluate Bayesian surprise
for the case of
a volatile environment with PC greater
than zero we show that in Proposition 8
the interpretation remained the same but
um
the equations become a bit more ugly so
that's why I don't bring it here but you
can check it out
so
having these three definitions here
something that's important is that piano
surprise could be written in terms of
the marginal probability
absolute error could be written in terms
of the Y hats for an estimate of an X
observation but for Bayesian surprise we
needed the whole belief because we had
to compute this expectation
and that's how we make our first
technical classification which is based
on the dependence on the belief that
this surprise definition how it depends
on belief pie
here on top we have PI from PI we can
extract the marginal probability and
from the marginal probability we can
extract one estimate the first group are
the observation mismatch surprise
definition that only depend on the
estimate for example the absolute error
that I introduced
the second group are the one that only
depends on the marginal probability
there are one like a Shannon surprise
that is minus logarithm of the marginal
probability but the last group they
cannot be evaluated by only knowing
these two variables by knowing this
distribution and the next prediction
denote the whole belief like Bayesian
surprise
so going back to this uh figure that I
show in the introduction
so far we have seen two definitions here
in this column two definitions here in
this column and two definitions here in
this column the first two absolute error
and shine on surprise were more about
the prediction so this one was saying
that what is the mismatch between the
prediction and observation and this one
was saying that How likely or unlikely
observation was while the Bayesian
surprise was saying that how much
information I gained upon this
observation
okay this was a technical classification
I can go forward now and discuss the
indistinguishable conditions before
going to indistinguishable condition I
want to introduce another definition of
surprise there is this uh opinion this
idea in the field that surprising events
increased learning rates and there are
some theory for it and there's some
experiment showing that it actually
happened so then there is something
surprising the learning rate increases
but there is this um
logical question that is increasing
learning rate always good for making
better predictions or making better
knowledge of the environment or not
because uh sometimes something surprise
something can be unlikely but if it is
just outlier maybe I should not change
my learning rate I should just ignore
this observation
what we find out
um is that there is a is necessary to
have a comparison between the current
belief and the prior belief because
basically the moment that you want to
increase your learning rate upon
surprising events is when there is a
change in the environment and you want
to say that I want to get rid of the old
observation
and this base Factor surprise we
proposed it in a paper in neural
computation in 2021
and it always compared the probability
of observation under the prior belief
with under the current belief it's some
sort of hypothesis testing at each point
saying that oh whether there was a
change or not
so if this um
the nominator the probability under the
prior belief if we ignore that this is
basically a decreasing function of the
probability under the current belief
very similar to the channel surprise
so there's the less likely an event the
more surprising it is but if that event
is also unlikely under the prior belief
then it may not be surprising
and um the reasoning
become more
valid when we show in our proposition
one in the paper that actually this
definition is optimal to modulate
learning
in proposition one we show that after
observing YT plus one the new belief can
be written in this term which is a
trade-off between integrating new
observation into the previous belief so
take the previous belief take the new
observation combine the two make a new
belief
or throw away the old belief say that oh
there was probably a change in the
environment I should reset from scr and
start from scratch and uh put the new
observation together with the prior
belief and make a reset belief and this
trade-off is controlled by something
that we call adaptation rates here shown
by gamma t plus one
which turned out to be an increasing
function of Base Factor surprise so the
higher base factors surprise the higher
adaptation rate and the higher
adaptation rate the more weight on the
reset
basically saying that the surprise uh
and this rule really comes out of the
Bayesian inference is a normative rule
and uh basically saying that base
factors surprise uh naturally emerge or
at least we Define it in a way to have
uh
this decomposition of the belief
in this paper we propose also a
variational method that turned out to be
have a very simple update rule for
distribution in exponential family which
we call a variational surprise
minimization learning and I would like
to mention here that recently it got
some applications in the active
inference community and people used it
for model building
so I introduced the base Factor surprise
as a new base uh surprise definition
let's go and just overview the
definitions that so far I showed the
first one was absolute error surprise
was in the family of observation
mismatch and it was it care about how
good my prediction is
then there was Channel surprise saying
How likely or an unlikely an observation
is it was again caring about prediction
but it was in the probabilistic mismatch
the base Factor surprise that I just
showed isn't the family of change Point
detection because as we saw it care
about whether there was a change point
or not
but it is still in the probabilistic
mismatch to price definition
[Music]
and another definition that I showed was
uh Bayesian surprise which was the
difference between uh prior previous
belief and the new belief
and is in the belief mismatch to price
definitions
um although they are in different
columns uh in different boxes one can
ask this question that is there any link
between Shannon's surprise uh here and
the base Factor surprise here because at
least there's one term that is repeated
in both definitions
that's what we show uh in the
preposition two of the paper
that Shannon's the the base Factor
surprise can be written as function of
these interesting things here that are
not Channel surprise
but very interestingly related to the
channel surprise there are difference in
Shannon's surprise so there are
different between the Shannon surprise
under the current belief and under the
prior belief
so
base Factor surprise can be written as a
function of difference in Channel
surprise so one may say that a base
Factor surprise has a interpretation
like a relative surprise and in that
sense it always compared the prior
belief with the current belief and
that's why it's good for learning
as a consequence in corollary one you
can argue that optimal surprise
modulation of learning can also be
written in terms of these differences
instead of the base factors to price
but the most fun thing is that in
corollary 2 we can
we show that if the marginal probability
under the prior belief is uniform so if
basically it means that if this term is
constant then there are strictly
increasing mappings between base Factor
surprise and two definition of Shannon
surprise
and strictly increasing mappings
basically means that these are
one-to-one uh
function of each other so they're
invertible and if I have one of them I
can find the other two so in a way
they're indistinguishable
and that's one of the big results of our
paper that's
the uh I identify the conditions under
which different definitions are
indistinguishable
so here in this figure you see different
definitions they are connected to each
other with lines each line corresponds
to one of these conditions that if this
condition is satisfied then these two
definitions are indistinguishable
and uh C2 here means that
this condition is proved under corollary
two in the paper
why this uh indistinguishability
conditions are important
um the first thing is for experiment
design for example let's take the um
Oddball test that I introduced before
usually an oddball task it is assumed
that uh marginal distribution under the
prior belief is flat because there's no
preference for the uh at the beginning
there is no preference between the blue
disk and the Red Square as a result
basically means that in this kind of
experiment all these five definitions
that I have here are indistinguishable
so I cannot do the Oddball task and
expect to see a difference between these
five definitions
in addition some people argue that even
the prior belief is flat and if is that
the case then these two definitions are
indistinguishable
even more because Oddball task is a
categorical task it is one of the
special cases that we identify which
basically means that
seven of these definitions are
indistinguishable so it's quite
important that if we want to make
experiment to distinguish some of these
uh surprise definitions to study
different definitions of surprise we
should be careful to
not have experiment where these are
indistinguishable and what we do is that
we take a series of papers in the field
that have experiments
where they study different definitions
of surprise and we identified which of
these conditions are satisfied or not in
these papers
the second thing that these industry
increasability condition can be
important for is for computational
modeling there is this page this new
preprint from orlab and Via archive
they're um
the authors show that they design a
spiking neural network that try to learn
in a volatile environment and modulate
its learning rate with the notion of
surprise
in the setting that they analyze we can
show that these three lines the
condition corresponding to these three
lines are satisfied so basically these
definitions of surprise are equivalent
what is uh
why this is interesting for us because
this one is optimal for learning is the
base Factor surprise that I showed
before while this one is pretty easy to
implement while base Factor surprise was
a function of probabilities well this
one is the observation space and that's
actually the fun thing that what they do
here is they make a spiking Network that
computes something related to this
observation mismatch surprise
definitions while there are some uh
optimal justification for why these um
surprise definition can be helpful for
learning
so putting together so far I proposed
the I presented the technical
classification that we proposed and
indistinguishability condition that we
found out
and now I'm going to discuss the
taxonomy
uh
I had 40 minutes so I still have time
right I can
so for your taxonomy I need to introduce
another definition I promise is the last
definition that I uh introduced today
it's um the notion of confidence
correction I want to introduce that and
there is this idea that higher
confidence higher confidence must lead
to higher feeling of surprise so the
more confident you are about your
predictions the more surprise you should
feel
energy at all uh in this paper proposed
this definition
uh it may look a bit strange at the
moment I would demystify it in a bit
it's the difference between the current
belief and after observing this
observation
how much uh what would be my belief if I
would cons if I would throw out all the
previous observation and make a new
belief so it's a next belief but
with the assumption that there was a
reset just for a comparison between the
confidence corrected surprise and
Bayesian surprise in the base and
surprise I had a difference between the
current belief and the next actual
updated belief
but for the confidence corrected
surprise is the current belief with the
reset updated belief
uh the reason that is interesting is
that in proposition 9 of the paper we
show that this definition can be written
in this way where the first name is
different in Shannon surprise the second
term is kind of difference is based on
surprise and the third term is a notion
of confidence
so this one looks like a relative
surprise as I argued before it's good
for uh modulation of learning and that
was actually the original plan of
Heritage at all to find the surprise
definition that is good for surprise
modulation
and the last term is a notion of
confidence and in these pre-print online
we show in some situation uh it seems
more intuitive to have some confidence
correction in the definition but I don't
want at the moment to
um enter that discussion I just want to
introduce that there are this class of
definitions with a confidence correction
an overview of all definitions so far
the absolute error but the difference
between observation and prediction in
this class
Shannon's surprise how unlikely
something is base Factor surprise uh how
unlikely something is compared to a
baseline or prior belief
the Asian surprise how um how much I
gain information upon observing
something and confidence corrected
surprise I should include the explicit
notion of confidence
having these five definitions now we saw
one definition per row and one
definition or at least one definition
per column
now I can introduce our taxonomy
on the on the screen now you see in a
seemingly arbitrary order these
definitions that I had here
and we propose to label these different
definitions based on the quantity they
measure
this group that's what we call a
prediction surprise they care about how
good your prediction is about the next
observation
this group where information gains
surprise they measure how much you learn
based on a new observation and these
groups for change Point detection
surprise that were some sort of relative
measures of surprise
and we had this uh overlapping labeling
that no matter where there is a
prediction or change Point detection we
can make the effect stronger or we can
correct the effects by adding an
explicit term for uh confidence
one can I ask that okay so far I talk
about vendor indistinguishable and put
them in different category one can ask
how different are these definition in
practice because if I um
pick a random Oddball task from the
field look at the data all these
definitions look quite correlated
and uh one may argue that okay
does it really matter to have different
definitions
and um
it is actually possible to design
experiments here I'm showing one example
I'm not going to discuss that what is
the experiment to be presented in this
preprints on the x-axis you see time on
the y-axis average surprise and four
definition from these four different
categories and here is a change point in
the environment and we see after change
point they have a completely different
Behavior one goes down one has Spike one
goes down and go up again and down again
so there are possibilities to make
Theory or even experiments that
different definitions of surprise can
have very different behavior and
different predictions
another example is um
in this preprint the focus and the role
of different surprise definitions and uh
curiosity or even exploration that how
differently they can drive exploration
and um there are also many other works
and that are not from our lab and they
work and they focus on the physiological
signatures of different definition of
surprise particularly this one is in
Pillars computational biology I found it
quite impressive they found signatures
in EEG for all three groups of
prediction surprise confidence
correction surprise and Information Gain
surprise so a fixed tax a fixed
experiment looking at the EEG they could
see that all these three have their own
correlates or signatures in the EG
signal
so I introduced the mathematical
framework
and formally discussed many definitions
of surprise we had this technical
classification and distinguishability
conditions and the taxonomy
take on messages one surprise in
different experiments refer to different
definitions
these different definitions can be
classified based on on their dependence
on the belief on the subject's belief
and the quantity they measure which was
the taxonomy or the labeling we proposed
and the third message under specific
condition some of these definitions are
indistinguishable and I argued that it
is useful for experiment design and also
useful for computational modeling
so putting everything together back to
this figure that I showed at the
beginning of the presentation
our proposition is to replace or at
least order these different signals or
definitions
in a structured way that
um
it
we can now uh if you put it in this
structured way let me rephrase it in
this way that then we can talk about
that oh for example for exploration
reaches these different domains is more
relevant is uh the belief is my surprise
definitions that are more relevant to
acceleration or the observation is my
surprise definition so we are not
talking about only specific definitions
but more like categories
um in addition to this uh surprise
related signal or these surprise
definitions we argue that there's also a
need for uh novelty signals or novelty
definitions
and um
we argue in this paper that novelty and
surprise are fundamentally different so
everything that I said today would not
uh stand for
novelty
so I would like to thank my um
collaborators for this joint work or
very cool lab in lausanne and you for
your attention thank you very much
and you all right just getting things
back awesome
I will restore our videos well thanks
for that awesome talk if anyone has a uh
question in the uh live chat please feel
free otherwise Ali if you'd like you can
re-enable your video and feel free to
give a first comment or I'm happy to
give a comment but you can go first uh
yeah sure but for some reason I can't
activate my camera here
uh
uh let me check it again okay
uh so thanks a lot
uh first of all I congratulate you for
writing and your of course your
co-authors for writing such a
fascinating paper
thank you I truly enjoyed it
uh well I have some
um comments if I may and
um also I have uh maybe a couple of
questions
uh
your work actually these kinds of
classification work or the taxonomy is
in my opinion is really a significant
contribution to the whole area of
psychological or especially in cognitive
Sciences because as
Muhammad Ali khalidi's recent book The
cognitive ontology claims this kind of
taxonomic approaches has been long
debated among the neuroscientists
psychologists and cognitive scientists
especially uh about the difference
between cognitive kinds and natural
kinds and whether or how they map unto
each other because as you also mentioned
we have a folk psychological notion of
surprise or uh let's say cognitive uh
kind of surprise but
we're not always clear about how to
translate that into precise mathematical
terms so I remember in active inference
book by par pazulo and Kristen there's
about a paragraph or so distinguishing
between the folk psychological notion of
surprise and the statistical surprise or
surprisal functions
corresponding to various distributions
so basically as I see it your paper is a
kind of expansion on that single
paragraph to consolidate all the
different conceptions of surprises into
a whole unified framework we were
talking the other day
about the importance and significance of
the recent move toward applied category
Theory as a kind of as I like to call it
the conceptual housekeeping or better
still a kind of cartography of the
knowledge trained so this this kind of
research
in my opinion can be seen in congruence
with this recent move
toward as Toby Sinclair Smith would call
well to do a kind of well-typed science
to be
precise and clear about our definitions
uh and uh I also wanted to uh kind of
getting back to that uh distinction
between the cognitive kinds and natural
kinds
um there are different taxonomic
approaches in cognitive science
addressing these problems uh but uh as I
understand it uh your work here is more
in line with the revisionism approach to
do these taxonomic uh these
classification approaches which says
that which which basically says the
current cognitive taxonomy is not
precise enough to adequately address uh
the problem of
uh distinguishing between cognitive
kinds and natural kinds so we need a
more precise formalism to do that
reminds me of uh Dalton's active advil's
notion of blanket index introduced in
his paper a week a mark of blankets
because before
before the publication of that paper
there was much confusion and ambiguities
about the exact mathematical definition
of the markup blanket or to put it in
other words to make it more General and
more precise what do we mean exactly by
Mark of blanket so my question is
as I see it uh so far you have
a somehow mapped these kinds of
different surprises
in a kind of discrete space as you
showed in one of your tables
so do you see it as a feasible move
forward
or let's say a feasible move toward more
General conception of this framework by
conceiving
this unified framework as as a
two-dimensional continuous
or n dimensional continuous manifold of
possible definitions of surprises and
maybe even Define an index to navigate
this continuous manifold space because
in that case
obviously you could the problem possibly
avoid
um those kind of blank
blank spaces you have on your tables and
maybe even we can gain a kind of a much
deeper insight into how exactly those
different kinds of surprises relate to
each other in a much more continuous
sense rather than the discrete stance so
do you think this kind of move even
feasible from your viewpoint
now that's a very good point uh thanks a
lot for the for all the remarks I
enjoyed it very much
um
the way that I Define surprise in a
general sense was this function or
functional that get the Q observation
and the belief and map it to a real
value number so all the types of
functional in this space can be seen as
a measure of surprise so the whole Space
is quite big and uh
continuous uh so in principle yes of
course we can do that but the space is
too big actually we need to put some
constraint on it so I think for future
work if one want to go to that direction
uh one should say that what are the
properties from a surprise definition
that I would like to have so put some
constraint on this space and then in
some sense uh parameterize this this
space to have some interpretation
because at the moment I'm saying that
okay let's look at this part of this
space that these definitions were there
people are already talking about these
definitions and I would call these
definitions for example Information Gain
surprise definitions so maybe one can
really uh formalize all the definitions
that it is possible to call
because okay I only talk about these two
particular definitions with kale
Divergence if you replace scale
Divergence with any measure of uh
distance on the space of uh
probabilities we end up with another
information in Surprise definition so I
think it is feasible in principle but I
think it's a bit of a tedious job and uh
whether how how useful it's going to be
is not clear for me because we already
have many definitions and as I try to in
a way say
what justify definition is at the end of
the day how useful it is to explain
experimental evidence and help us think
about cognition
Justified true belief distribution
um
thank you irreza want to add a general
comment and then bring us back to active
inference so
in exploring the active inference
ontology we've often found this tension
where a given term would have one
definition very folk psychological very
everyday
belief surprise observation sense action
these are some of the most common words
in any language and then your work
started to dissect or characterize due
taxonomics on that Iceberg and show that
the pointer of a given word surprise in
this case can actually host uh diversity
of technical definitions with some
subtle
contradictions or compatibilities and
areas of indistinguishability so I think
it really
um raises our attention to the Horizon
and shows that for a lot of terms that
people again use in a day-to-day context
there may be multiple definitions and
there's many implications like there
isn't a single way to model action or
belief or surprise
there are different flavors and even
within a flavor there's going to be
different ways to deploy it in a given
model or script or modeling context so I
think the formal
coherences that you're providing are
going to go a long way to ensuring that
given that kind of pluralism in modeling
and statistics which has always been the
case that we do have connections that
are robust to enable comparison like you
did with different empirical setups
whether the experimenters understood sh1
versus sh2
we can
um post hoc essentially as peer review
annotate or augment the definitions
re-partition different ways that they
analyzed data and so I I think that
really opens up a lot of directions
something that you had on several slides
but didn't really go into that much was
F star
so could you add a little bit on free
energy
what is free energy what's free about it
what's energetic about it why do we use
it to
help us engage in perception cognition
action in the free energy principle and
active inference
thanks a lot for the question
um the way that I see free energy in the
context of what I discuss about is as
long as I talk about exact Bayesian
inference and really have my exact
update rule for the uh for the belief
going from the previous observation and
previous belief to the exact next belief
uh free energy doesn't play much of a
role free energy plays a role as soon as
I want to talk about approximate
inference and go to the variational
setting and in that case basically free
energy defines
um some loss between my approximation
and the exact true belief
and one can show that this is the upper
Bound for the Shannon surprise that they
Define
and the difference between the the free
energy and these uh final surprise is
how good my approximation is and that's
why if I do exact inference the minimize
for energy is equal to the channel
surprise so in that sense I cannot
really distinguish minimize free energy
from Channel surprise but if I work in
the uh approximate inference setting
then minimize free energy is the best
approximation of Shannon surprise that I
can get
by
like this in that framework
yeah
awesome
just to kind of restate that because
it's actually one of the fundamental
aspects of the approach taken in active
inference if the true state of the world
is a gaussian and we're doing exact
inference with the gaussian prior
we will seek to minimize our Shannon's
surprise
we could
if the world is not truly a gaussian but
it's some other unstated or unstatable
distribution but we choose to do
variational approximate Bayesian
inference with a gaussian prior then
free energy tracks us doing strictly as
well as we could
given our choice of Prior family and so
it operationalizes with approximate
Bayesian computational techniques
these formal definitions which may or
may not be tractable in large State
spaces or with large amounts of data so
it's a super important point and it's
almost like there's that Iceberg of
surprise definitions and then free
energy
ports us into the approximate
which enables us to to get some
tractability in settings where inexact
Bayesian approach is not plausible
okay two things first is even more than
that so uh even
no matter what is world
I may assume that world is a
as a quotient distribution let's say but
there's some dependency and I still even
though I'm aware of this dependency I
can assume that there's no dependency
and do that in my uh inference so when I
think about the world it is actually
true I I believe that there are
dependency but they still do approximate
inference so I think when we do
variational inference we may not
necessarily care that what is the true
distribution we assume the distribution
has this form the yet we want to
approximate it with something simpler
uh this is the first part and the second
part
all the definitions of surprise that I
talked about can be applied to this
approximate uh
setting as well so I can use the belief
approximate belief that I found with
variational uh inference and just
imported in any of the definition that I
had and come up with some definitions of
surprise I think what I want to
emphasize on is that variational free
energy and minimize free energy is one
of this particular one but all of them
are still applicable in the approximate
variational setting
thank you for the correction like you
mentioned variational free energy and
there is expected free energy about
future but also people have proposed
variants like the free energy of the
expected future and so it speaks to
categories of functionals
that do different computations and there
isn't just one specific functional form
they might highlight different aspects
as your plot of surprisal through time
let's just say it was some stimuli
and I think that leads to
um a next question which is if we're
interested in some biological phenomena
how does this work
help shape our experimental design
statistical power analysis
discussion section like how do the
thousands of papers surely using
surprise in a qualitative or a
quantitative way
how do we translate this work to
increase the rigor and interoperability
of those studies
that's a very good question uh and
that's somehow the ideal uh place that I
want or paper to be used that uh it
makes a framework
uh that we can think in a very formal
way that if I wanted to design an
experiment to distinguish these two
different Notions
what would my generated what was the
necessary necessary features that my
generative model need to have and how
can I uh make the realization of that
generative model in an experimental
paradigm what we do for example in the
preprint uh is not in the main paper
using a preprint that is online it's a
and bio archive with the same set of
authors there we try to find situations
that for example it's a some election
situation that each week before the
election is on the news media tell you
that uh this party is going to win with
this probability then you see the
results and we try to make some
assumption that what are the features of
these uh experiments and what we see is
that oh actually different definitions
make very different predictions so I
cannot give a systematic approach that
oh okay this is the algorithm that if
you want to design an experiment just go
one by one these steps but I want to say
that this framework gives us the tools
to think about before doing the
experiment how to design it to have the
maximal effect in many of these also
indistinguishability conditions I say
for example that if something is flat
these two definitions are
indistinguishable the thing is that if
that distribution is not flat the two
are distinguishable but the effects that
is very small if it is close to flat so
the best thing is that if I want to make
two uh definition of surprise is
indisting
distinguishable in an experiment then
it's best to look at that condition
and make the opposite of that condition
in my experiment and in that way I make
the FX size as big as possible in some
sense it's a very um
non-rigorous way of talking about uh the
theory but just intuitively that's how
we design those experiments and could
convince or experimental colleague at
the moment to run the experiment so we
are doing that
awesome yeah there's a lot of ways that
we could imagine
pre-registration of studies and just the
development of templates and patterns
for statistical analyzes so that
different kinds of surprise could be
highlighted and we could say if the
change point is going to be like this
then you will be able to distinguish
with this power these kinds of outcomes
versus another um Ali do you want to
question or
yeah I actually this discussion reminds
me of uh Terence Deacon's uh famous
paper uh what is missing from theories
of information
uh because uh in that paper he also
claims that one of the misunderstandings
about uh all the uh theories of
information or all the relevant uh
theories for that matter is the
assumption that
in order for any information to have
a kind of
for any content of information to have
any real world consequences
it must have some substantial properties
and must of correspond to some real
world situations or something present as
an extrinsic entity in some form another
but as he shows in that paper we can
regard the information whether as a kind
of probability distribution or any kind
of other theoretical construct
as
exactly conveying the kind of
information that uh we want we wanted to
explore in a much real sense and it's
not just pure data or pure uh
abstract information for that
so for instance uh Shannon's analysis of
information of course is based on the
constraint and the entropy but on the
other hand the capacity to convey that
information is uh it depends on the
relation to something that is
specifically absent or not produced so
this absence or presence of the entities
that the information is about that
entity or so-called the aboutness of the
information is
I heard the aboutness of the information
but we'll pause and see if he'll rejoin
otherwise we can continue
okay
I'll just kind of
do you want to provide a thought on
Shannon or just uh yeah that's actually
very um important point that uh Ali was
about to talk about uh which is
in all these uh
definition that I propose we didn't
really care about uh what is uh why or
what is X we were working in these very
abstract States and a very abstract
framework one may say that what if I
don't care about these observations at
all and I still may have some
predictions and uh
so this aboutness that you were talking
about is quite important and whether I
no matter how confident I am or what is
my prediction how much I care about that
problem is quite important and how
surprised I am if I don't care about it
at all then I may not feel surprised at
all
um so that's something that's really
missing from the whole framework that
how we can model the
um
the the other things that have let's say
semantic because at the moment uh all
the framework is semantic free
uh how how can we include some uh
semantic into this framework we can talk
about uh
then we have another dimension to talk
about surprise
yes
and some hope that with
Progressive
syntax schemes
we can partition that semantics into
other surprise definitions
but the bigger question is what are we
surprised about and I think that
connects to these other cognitive
phenomena slash
complex word complexes like attention
confidence salience
um and I mean just to kind of put a
point on that like when surprise is
being used as an imperative for
optimization and inference or merely as
a signal that plays into action
selection
your robot or Aunt or person or software
is gonna do different things depending
on the surprise
formalisms used
and knowing many flavors of formalism
it would be awesome if we could have a
software package that computes 18
different numbers
but then what would we do we could
choose one we could blend them we could
make summary statistics we could say
that we're in zone a where these five
are aligned but this one isn't and then
what would we do with that action how
surprised would we be by that
location and phase space
so it's like a very interesting
top-down
situation independent phrasing of those
relationships but in the implementation
it's always going to come down to what
the modeler chooses
there just isn't a general answer to be
found in the specifics
one other thought
or area to explore is
you mentioned the Bayes factor and its
role in learning so could you speak to
optimal Bayesian inference and optimal
learning
what do you mean sorry and you like
Bayes optimal inference
okay that's what I meant that base
Factor surprise appear in base optimal
learning and also appear in the
variational uh Bayesian update Rule and
that was actually what we found cool
about it because neuroscientists
particularly people talking about the
synaptic plasticity talked about
surprise and how neuromodulators
influence synaptic plasticity
and we saw that if you're looking at the
Bayesian framework we can find that such
normative modulation based on surprise
exist
in how the belief is updated and it is
funny that the same thing appear in lots
of approximate inference scheme as well
and it seems necessary to use such a
surprise measures to modulate learning
as we learn and there are lots of
experimental evidence for it
um so
what I want to say is not necessarily
only about the exact base and inference
but it is something that appeared there
and is useful for also other kind of uh
other approximation to exact inference
so what does optimal learning in this
case mean
um
optimal learning
means to find the exact posterior
given the model for those parameters
because if the model is true if I
believe that this is the true model
the optic all the information that I can
have about the hidden variable
is in the posterior distribution of that
variable given the observations
and basically what we mean by learning
is to
um updating this uh posterior
distribution from one time to another so
as we go on and add more and more data
points how we track this distribution
over time and how we update our belief
and by Optimal learning we mean the
exact up Bayesian update from time T to
T Plus 1. but this could be done also
with variational inference
but the cool thing was that also Bank
variational inference would benefit from
such modulation
so one thought on that in a little bit
of a
a meta science area is Bayesian
statistics is becoming more prevalent
and one way of reporting the effect of a
treatment would be like with a base
factor to present the relative evidence
for one model versus another and
something that that plays a functional
similarity with but of course a
technical difference is a p-value and so
in the presentation I thought about how
the base Factor
was associated with learning as well as
we could
representing the evidence for two
different possibilities in a ratio
whereas a p-value especially when we put
um a discontinuity 0.05
is like a change point
it's like we're sampling from the
experimental outcomes and eggs are
healthy eggs are healthy eggs are
healthy now there's a difference between
the groups
so that puts the task of Science and
learning into a change Point detection
framework
where oh now we're in the world where
this is the case
versus the sort of unrolling Bayesian
approach
where we get
some experimental results
that are all over the posterior
but merely drawing results from a
potentially quite dispersed
posterior
doesn't mean that we've entered any
change point with respect to the
efficacy of a given treatment
I'm trying to uh
to connect what you said about science
in general to what you were thinking
just as a point that the base Factor
surprise we really took the word base
factor from the field of statistics for
the nature of hypothesis testing that
exists in these kind of change Point
detection because at each point you want
to see that oh okay was there really a
change in the environment or not and uh
for example for this uh
weather forecast
in the pandemic I really had this before
knowing that uh this is really a
phenomenon and weather forecasts get
less accurate for a couple of weeks I
was confused that okay what's going on
why my uh metal Swiss is not working uh
well anymore
so it's always some sort of hypothesis
testing that okay am I living in the
same world that it was yesterday
or something changed from yesterday so
there is some hypothesis testing and in
the Bayesian setting it's done by
comparing two models to base Factor but
we can also have even in the Bayesian
setting if we go again towards
approximate Bayesian setting and
sampling like the particle filtering we
sample this change pouring so at some
point we make decisions that uh oh this
is the probability of for example
there's a change or not at some point I
should decide I would say yeah there is
a change and from today onward I behave
as if something changed yesterday
and uh in a frequentis approach
is a bit difficult for me to include
things like p-value in the framework
that I was talking about because the
nature of p-value is in talking about
probability of things more extreme than
things that already happened while in
this Bayesian setting we are talking
about this particular observation I
don't care about the values higher than
observation lower than observation
different from I I care about only this
observation well in p-value we compute
the probability of observation more
extreme than this one
and um
and I don't see how it can easily fit in
the framework but if I want to find the
closest measure to say that it's a bit
similar to p-value I would say it's
something like Shannon's surprise
because it doesn't have the nature of
comparison you just say that under the
current belief which let's say that the
null hypothe is the current hypothesis
how unlikely is the new observation
yes one could certainly apply a change
Point base Factor over three means we
publish the paper base Factor under
three is no
evidence and there's definitely some
subtlety there with what the P statistic
and other empirically calculated
statistics
tell us
I'll read one question from the chat
then Ali so Dave writes
have folks working on these problems
modeled the situation where counter
evidence has no impact on confidence
delusion and cognitive dissonance are
terms that come into that discussion
I'm sorry can you read again because I
opened the page to read it myself as
well but then all good have folks
working on these problems model the
situation where counter evidence has no
impact on confidence delusion and
cognitive dissonance are terms that come
into that discussion
that counter evidence doesn't have
effect and confidence
that was yes potentially where
um surprising beliefs are continually
entertained
how could we model a situation where
persistence
uh cognitive dissonances or delusive
beliefs are stabilized
okay
about cognitive doesn't
when I talk about hypothesis testing in
a Bayesian setting the fun thing is that
all hypotheses live at the same time you
just change the weight over them and
some of these hypothesis are in
disagreement with each other
so this
counterfactual assumptions that oh what
if there was a change a while ago or
what if uh
oh wait
no the previous observations are fixed
I have this uh
I have this imagination only in the
unobserved States and when I talk about
uh different scenarios I talk about
unobserved States
what
um
I think the question was about
if I want to think about counterfactuals
then I should imagine that how would the
world be if the observation was
different
and that at the moment is not included
in the framework
but one could think about it if we would
uh integrate the framework it's a bit of
causal inference
and in those settings we have this
counteractual and talking about now I
don't only condition in the past I
imagine that some of the observation is
very different and now I do my inference
but I'm not sure if I got the question
and if my answer was relevant I hope it
is uh
related
awesome and on that
um response Ian wrote cognitive
dissonance I think there's something to
do with having different beliefs at
different levels of consciousness so yes
these
taxonomies were presented at a single
level model as presented and with nested
models we might have
um different interactions amongst
surprise definitions maybe even
different surprise definitions playing
out within a nested Bayesian
architecture
maybe one type of surprise is more
amenable to Edge detection in the retina
and then in a different part of the
generative model there's another Opera
operationalization of surprise in a
decision making or in a risk aversive
setting
of course that's uh definitely the case
that different
level of processing may work with
different levels of surprise and
um maybe I don't know uh belief
mismatched price definitions are not
relevant for the primary uh part of
Cortex at all
but
if that's the case yeah I understand but
uh maybe I misunderstood what they mean
by cognitive
Ollie any more thoughts or questions
maybe we can each have one more question
or
contribution
yeah actually uh first of all I
apologize I got disconnected in the
middle of my question I don't know uh
how much it was fine I could yeah uh all
right so one thing about these kind of
nested hierarchies
um is that in the interactivist
framework uh they usually uh Define
different kinds of information as
different levels of emergence in a kind
of nested hierarchy uh the biggest of
all is the Shannon information which
deals with the kind of medium capacity
of
um conveying the information and then uh
on another emergence level is uh the
referential information which is about
the aboutness
and
um at the highest emergence level we
have the significant information or uh
as they would like to call the
usefulness or the semantic content of
the information
as they say so my question is that uh
this kind of tax taxonomic approach that
you uh
provided in this paper uh how can we map
this taxonomic system or even whether we
can map this kind of taxonomic system
into this kind of nested hierarchies of
different information because obviously
uh we can probably even say that the
nature of these different kinds of
informations are different right
um my short answer would be
the table that I showed
if we want to account for the things
that you discussed we should make a few
of those tables so we should add another
dimension so I don't think it's really
possible to map this particular
definitions to those different uh
categories
uh
and for the long answer
I give again another short answer which
is basically we need to make a new
framework to really include all these
semantics or current probabilistic
framework the one that I presented today
doesn't have the capacity to uh account
for that
yeah that's why I mentioned that in
manifold thing I said my first question
because I was thinking of something
similar because uh maybe uh in order to
generalize this framework we would need
a lot more Dimensions than uh just the
two Dimensions that we have already
provided in the paper so uh I don't know
if as you say if it would be
useful for any uh future research or
whether it would be any kind of
attractable uh computational framework
but at least in my opinion or from
purely theoretical point of view
maybe it's worth investigating to see
how these kinds of different Frameworks
uh integrate into a much more
generalized way of thinking about
information and surprise but as I said
your paper is a very important and
significant contribution in that regard
so in near closing the
taxonomy notion it's a classification
scheme and just as in Biology
early Natural History observations of
different things led to taxonomics and
the classification of different things
and on through phylogenetics and
understanding the the temporal
relationships so today we have a
taxonomy for surprise that we didn't
have
a year ago
what can be contributed by your group
and by others in this emerging ecology
of formalisms
if we have the taxonomy today just a
sketch napkin sketch two by two grid we
sorted the birds that people saw into
roughly these categories they don't even
know that it was this bird but now we
can disambiguate it was that bird
so
where will you be heading
in this space and where do you think
there are areas for people to contribute
to this living area
that's a very good point a very good
question uh there is this slide that I
had these different four domains of uh
learning exploration memory and
physiological signals that people talk
about surprise in neuroscience and
psychology in the middle these different
definitions I think
if you want to go beyond the taxonomy
we should try to do more computational
modeling and see that which of these
definitions which part of these two
degrees is related to which of these uh
function so basically now I'm
just proposing some tools and a
framework which can be used later on for
computational modeling so all these
definitions can be useful or not for
some modeler to explain exploration in
some task or learning in some other
tasks or segmentation in some task so
going to be the next step is really
finding out where and what function this
definition makes sense
yes you brought up the novelty curiosity
learning and surprise is woven sometimes
technically or not into those
discussions
but it's not all definitions a surprise
for all definitions of learning salience
attention novelty so disambiguating that
space is very important
Ollie any final remarks
uh I would like to thank you again for
inviting me and
thanks a lot for all the discussion and
nice question oh awesome it's a great
honor and learning experience for us so
you're always welcome back till next
time
you're really appreciate it thanks any
reason thank you have a nice day bye-bye
very well bye